herzlich willkommen wie heute zu einer
neuen episode nicht
ich halte immer noch luca ich nenne ich
habe jetzt nur noch bernie sanders
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
mit mehr lächeln bei uns sind nicht
lachen ist eigentlich das einfach lachen
stelle du sagen kannst du mir mal
erklären was das jetzt sollen leiste das
getränk aus bringt davon und spuckt es
in die mülltonne eines tage erdin
fahrian keine alters hatten keine
gewinnt sie ist 2010 style alter 2010
safe oder wie nennt man die frisur
überhaupt pferdeschwanz naja ich sehe
keine ahnung wie verwachsen sind heute
war das volk umweltdaten sonst jetzt in
hof spielt sein vier jahre hält meine
frage ist ich habe den januar 1940 das
ist so und scheint das beste was ihr
gibt oder wie ich habe gar keine ahnung
ich will es auch nicht mache mich reizt
das auch gar nicht warum automaten so
sei diese wärme der ersten klasse und
ich konnte nicht mal ich hab mal die 10
cent übrig dass ich find's cool wenn
sich ältere menschen auf neuere dinge
einlassen überhaupt und seitdem ganz
meine chance beispiele sind der
direktion ist neu mag ich nicht früher
alles besser
das hast du überhaupt mit cap auf you
hat mich gezwungen werbung für sein
luckow sachen zu machen
comcom das musst du filmen sagt die frau
am fenster und sie hat recht denn was
die umzugs jungs da unten treiben
das sieht man nicht alle tage also nutze
letzter sein für alles nur noch auf
kürzungen einstellen wenn wir nicht mal
zeigt nur wie lang lang sagt das machen
meine umzugshelfern haben das ist
auffällt gefällt immer wieder darunter
stellt heute das x 8 war genau wie er
jetzt wie schnell
[Musik]
ich musste nur boxen noch ganz kurz
entziehen als heute abend gibt's buchs
will mit der adidas jogger ja die
menschen leben einen relativ normalen
alltag natürlich auch dass man keinen
elektrischen schlag bekommt weil er was
ein akku ist
[Musik]
ich liebe solche werte also ist das
turbo von galileo vertreter der
gasannahme trott
[Musik]
kann liter das ist talent das ist wahres
talent bruder
wir sind alle gewinner wir haben alle
das rennen der spitze wollen wir das
schnellste
neben dem fruchtwasser in der mutter
also liegt heute macht man ein bisschen
sport an die dicken garnen die abnehmen
wollen
[Gelächter]
bitte tut ist einfach weniger das echt
ne schwierige chatten scheiterte man
city entfachen wohl donuts
mindestbestellwert 90 euro lieferkosten
kommt dem eurokorps aus 41 euro
lieferkosten ehrlich später los
was sagen sie wenn ich das hier mache
wenn ich diesem laptop zerstöre einfach
so dass auf zdf.de geschäft eine
kollegin kann heute nicht arbeiten
kannst du heute für sie einspringen ich
doppelt grund
ich möchte schlafen wenn wir nachts um 4
uhr wurde hubble haben sie sowieso kommt
das gehirn wenn man nachts pendeln auf
so einen schwachsinn haben auch schon
drüber geht man führt doch immer so
konversationen die man nie führen wir zu
diskussionen zwar mietwagen die
situation aus die niemals stattfinden
wir in der tat nicht geteilt wieder ist
du fährst doch wenn wenn wenn endlich
sprachen lernen dadurch werde ein typ zu
dir kommt in dem vw golf hat er den
namen oder wird sich ein typ der nicht
so heißt es aber in einem arm geht
ja was du zu nehmen das ist wie er sagte
und hier haben wahllos senken
der wagen ist da er louis bacon und
lucky das heute tommy hilfiger eisen
mein englisch ist ist okay nein ob euro
bis zum little listen mit kindle und
kindle auf englisch wenn sie bringen wo
ich war so ich sagen hat es so
menschlich zu prüfen
die sache ist sandra und ich habe mir
einen podcast ethik und rufen da haben
wir schon relativ häufig dass andere
sätze auf russisch die ich auf deutsch
gesagt hat musste sie auf russisch
übersetzen musste ich mich mit der sache
immer hoch nehmen sondern du kommst aus
russland das ist eine nette sätze die
ich war da mal nehme ich jetzt so
richtig einfach okay ich fahre mit
meinem fahrrad bei villas zitiert mein
computer ist gestern kaputt was ist denn
der in russland ist und ein laptop ist
schrott dann geht es da ja auch hin sagt
mein computer ist gestern kaputt
gegangen
naja das immer so sein dass sie trotz
aller fristen beruhigt das sei das
richtige santander wenn die durch ihr
viertel läuft und dann mit kopfhörern
dann halt diese rom oder behindert er
sagt warum hast du so laut
ja die nach hause besser
die gern ich diesmal ins visier und will
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
an der stelle wenn ihr nicht das heutige
jetzt allerdings auch wenn meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese nicht lachen
challenge gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da sollen sander und ich eventuell das
öfter machen schreibt uns in den
kommentaren abonniert meinen kanal falls
doch keiner der hypo galt
[Musik]